en el juego de básquetbol las jirafas
anotaron 13 puntos menos que los
pingüinos y los pingüinos anotaron 87
puntos cuántos puntos se anotaron las
jirafas antes de tratar de resolver este
problema vamos a entender mejor lo que
nos están diciendo quienes anotaron más
puntos los pingüinos o las jirafas pues
nos dicen aquí las jirafas anotaron 13
puntos menos que los pingüinos entonces
los pingüinos son los que anotaron más
puntos y las jirafas anotaron 13 puntos
menos lo que se quedaron 13 puntos abajo
porque las jirafas anotaron 13 puntos
menos así es que las jirafas anotaron
menos puntos que los pingüinos por lo
que cualquiera que sea este número de
aquí va a ser más chico que 87 aunque
porque los pingüinos anotaron 87 puntos
y por cuántos puntos le ganaron los ping
las jirafas pues le ganaron por 13
puntos entonces cualquiera que sea este
número de aquí es la cantidad de puntos
que anotaron los pingüinos que nos dicen
por aquí que es 87 87 menos 13 porque
las jirafas anotaron 13 puntos menos así
es que tenemos que averiguar cuánto vale
esta resta que los pingüinos anotaron 87
puntos y las jirafas anotaron 13 puntos
menos 13 puntos menos de lo que anotaron
los pingüinos por lo que vamos a hacer
esta resta y lo que nos va a dar es la
cantidad de puntos que anotaron las
jirafas hagamos la resta empezamos por
el lugar de las unidades tenemos 7 - 3
gestos son 4 y luego pasamos al lugar de
las escenas
8 - 17
y listo los pingüinos anotaron 87 puntos
y las jirafas anotaron 13 puntos menos
que lo que anotaron los pingüinos
entonces si a 87 le quitamos 13 nos va a
quedar la cantidad de puntos que
anotaron las jirafas 13 puntos menos que
87 son 74 puntos y las jirafas anotaron
13 puntos menos que los pingüinos
entonces las jirafas anotaron 74 puntos